the the the the the the the the the the the
the the the the of it. They seem to belie what I was hearing in the media and you know for the last 20 years is what this all you've heard is the separation and how people are so radically different and and being the country's being torn apart and it's it's not being torn apart it's this it's just a it's a strange place we're in right now where we're trying to, I think, culturally understand what's real and what's not, and what's important and what's not in a bigger way, I think, than we had before.
the the the the of it. 它们似乎与我在媒体上听到的背道而驰。你知道，过去20年来你所听到的都是分裂，人们是多么的截然不同，国家正在被撕裂。但它并没有被撕裂，这只是我们现在所处的一个奇怪的地方，我认为我们正在努力从文化上理解什么是真实的，什么是虚假的，什么是重要的，什么是不重要的，而且是以一种比以前更宏大的方式。
There's personal identity, and then there's a cultural identity and a national identity. And it's out there, but you have to look for it. It doesn't come easy. You have to go find it. And I think there's such a problem now with people that will sit back on their couches and just let it come to them. the the different beauty there that I'm not completely used to. So it took a while to sort of jump into it, but you can find it there as well. You know, they have their own version of it
有个人身份，也有文化身份和国家身份。它就在那里，但你必须去寻找它。它不会轻易出现。你必须去发现它。我认为现在的问题在于，人们只会坐在沙发上，等着它送上门来。那种我不太习惯的别样美。所以花了一段时间才融入其中，但你也能在那里找到它。你知道，他们有他们自己的版本。
as every country does and every state does. But I think in the bigger picture, it's the connectivity of people. And you know, when I would approach these towns to take a photo in a little small town with 6,000 people in the middle of Nebraska, Florida, or California, or wherever, I would approach it.
正如每个国家和每个州都有一样。但我认为从大局来看，这是人与人之间的联系。你知道，当我接近这些城镇，想在内布拉斯加州、佛罗里达州、加利福尼亚州或任何地方的一个只有6000人的小镇拍照时，我会去接近它。
I had to approach it from a neutral spot and to know that there was something beautiful there that I couldn't dismiss it. Like I tried to dismiss Palmdale, California early on being an awful, like not a photogenic, not a pretty place. But I couldn't dismiss it. I had to find its beauty and then I had to see the beauty that was there and know that it was there when I approached it and then to be able to to find its specific beauty and then I realized that sort of to translate
我必须从一个中立的角度去接近它，并知道那里有一些美好的东西，我不能忽视它。就像我早先试图忽视加利福尼亚州的帕姆代尔，认为它很糟糕，不上镜，不是个漂亮的地方。但我无法忽视它。我必须找到它的美，然后我必须看到那里的美，并在我接近它时知道它的存在，然后才能找到它独特的美，然后我意识到那种翻译
accidentally equal afterwards so that was part of the connectivity too. Well thank you that's a beautiful intro I'm I'm here with Toby Huss who's an actor a photographer writer painter and star of so many things I love you in Halt and Catch Fire I love you in Sort of Trust the cops in the smokey room on the neo noir or one of the one of the guys in the back set and I think Houghton catch fire and sort of trust maybe two of my favorites and then you know king of the hill is great which I guess is coming back on soon but coming back on sort of trust has a visual language that looks very similar to your photo essay that we're talking about American sugar gristle I mean I think if you look at like cinematography or something that seems to be the closest to kind of what your,
事后偶然相等，所以这也是联系的一部分。嗯，谢谢你，这是一个很棒的开场白。我和托比·哈斯（Toby Huss）在一起，他是一位演员、摄影师、作家、画家，也是我非常喜欢的许多作品的主角。我喜欢你在《奔腾年代》（Halt and Catch Fire）中的表现，我喜欢你在《Sort of Trust》中饰演的那个在烟雾缭绕的房间里的警察，或者在《Back Set》中的那个人之一，我认为《奔腾年代》和《Sort of Trust》可能是我最喜欢的两部作品。然后你知道《乡巴佬希尔》（King of the Hill）也很棒，我想它很快就要回归了，但《Sort of Trust》有一种视觉语言，看起来和你正在谈论的摄影集《美国糖软骨》（American Sugar Gristle）非常相似。我的意思是，如果你看电影摄影之类的东西，那似乎是最接近你那种……
was there any kind of cross inspiration or anything there? And you mentioned Lynn Shelton in the book in one passage it looks like. Yeah. Yeah, she was a buddy of mine since 91 or something like that. We were in a theater company in New York together. So I've known her, I'd known her forever.
那里有任何交叉灵感吗？你在书中有一段提到了琳·谢尔顿（Lynn Shelton）。是的。是的，她从91年左右开始就是我的好朋友。我们曾一起在纽约的一家剧团工作。所以我认识她，我认识她很久了。
And she's just great. We did together on Glow and then we worked together on this thing and oh yeah, Dickinson. She directed an episode of Dickinson. It's just great. And she's an old pal and she's really talented. And like we never got to spend as much time together. We were only like together on sets
她真的很棒。我们一起合作了《美女摔角联盟》（Glow），然后我们一起做了这件事，哦对了，还有《狄金森》（Dickinson）。她导演了《狄金森》的一集。她真的很棒。她是我的老朋友，非常有才华。我们从来没有机会花足够多的时间在一起。我们只是一起在片场
when we were hiking one time. But that was the first time in 10 years. We'd have breakfast now and again, but it was never like a relationship that, you know, it's hard with her because you want more of her. And I'm sure everybody felt that. She's one of those people that you're around her.
有一次我们去徒步旅行。但那是10年来第一次。我们偶尔会一起吃早餐，但这从来不是那种……你知道，和她在一起很难，因为你想要更多地了解她。我相信每个人都有这种感觉。她是那种你和她在一起时……
You're like, yeah, let's have more of this, this is, she's just that wonderful kind of human that, you know, had a lot of friends and a lot of people that, that cared about her and were invested in her. And in that way, you kind of invest in your friends. And, and sometimes it, it, it comes back and sometimes not, but that's not why you invest in that. You just do it because you like that thing, that person. And there are some people that just have such a generativity and an expansiveness. It's just like you feel like you could just go forever almost.
你会觉得，是的，让我们多一点这样的时光，她是那种美妙的人，你知道，有很多朋友，很多人关心她，并为她投入感情。以这种方式，你也会投入到你的朋友身上。有时它会有回报，有时没有，但那不是你投入的原因。你只是因为喜欢那个人才这么做。有些人就是有这种创造力和广阔的胸怀。感觉就像你可以永远和他们在一起。
They're always just kind of pulling everyone in. Yeah, we had that way about her. Well, so a lot of American Sugar Gristle, the stuff that you write is not quite poetry, not quite prose. It's almost dreamlike, trying to orient yourself into what you're hearing and where you're coming in. It's interesting, they're almost like conversations that maybe you had in this place. Maybe you're just looking at the setting and you're thinking about
他们总是把每个人都吸引过来。是的，她就是那样。嗯，所以《美国糖软骨》中很多你写的东西，既不是诗也不是散文。它几乎是梦幻般的，试图让你适应你所听到的和你所进入的地方。很有趣，它们几乎就像你在这个地方可能进行的对话。也许你只是看着环境，然后你在思考
conversations that may occur there, these characters just emerge out of the ether. It's really pretty, but like your character in sort of trust hog jaws, that almost seems like it would be a line from American Sugar. Some of those lines would kind of accompany. I think that that's what I bring to the things that I make is something that's pretty specifically the That's not why you hired me. You hired me to do all this husnus and now you're trying to squash it. Yeah, I think that I've always loved language like that and some of the stories are autobiographical or they start with an autobiographical seed. And some of them are just like the one toward the end
可能在那里发生的对话，这些角色只是从以太中浮现出来。这真的很美，但就像你在《Sort of Trust》中饰演的角色Hog Jaws一样，那听起来几乎像是《美国糖软骨》中的台词。其中一些台词会伴随而来。我认为这就是我带给我所创作作品的东西，这是非常具体的……那不是你雇我的原因。你雇我是为了做所有这些哈斯式的东西，现在你却想压制它。是的，我想我一直很喜欢那样的语言，有些故事是自传性的，或者它们以自传性的种子开始。有些只是像接近结尾的那一个
where it's about the guy shooting the other guy to avenge his sister. That's an autobiographical story. That's my old roommate in New York who's since passed away. Made a pretty rough life, but that's what we figured happened to him. And I'd lost touch with him a little bit toward the end of his life. That's a true one.
关于那个为了给妹妹报仇而枪杀另一个人的家伙。那是一个自传性的故事。那是我在纽约的老室友，他已经去世了。生活过得很艰难，但这就是我们认为发生在他身上的事。在他生命的最后阶段，我和他失去联系了。那是一个真实的故事。
Then the penis that somebody spray painted on the Shell gas station. There's a lot of penises in the book. I like all of the dick graffiti. That's one of the more American elements to me. You don't see that. Well, you think it's American. the the and I thought of course like every other dude which I didn't want hey I should run in the shape of a big cock through my wonderfully pure aisle, I think too, and very organic and authentic about things like that that you see when you drive around the country. And the reason why I included the one, the gas pump, not because I think graffiti dicks are hilarious, but just I immediately thought of the conversation
还有某人在壳牌加油站喷漆画的那个阴茎。书里有很多阴茎。我喜欢所有的鸡巴涂鸦。对我来说，那是更具美国特色的元素之一。你不会看到那个。嗯，你认为它是美国的。我像其他男人一样想，当然，我不想，嘿，我应该在我的纯净岛屿上画一个大鸡巴的形状，我也认为，对于你在全国各地开车时看到的那些东西，非常有机和真实。我之所以把那个加油泵包括进去，不是因为我觉得涂鸦鸡巴很搞笑，而是因为我立刻想到了对话
of the two dudes who were hanging out. They were like 16, 17 year olds slackers from, I think, Duke and Kerry, something like that. It could have been Duke and Kerry, but it was one of those little the the I started laughing more thinking that's hilarious. And then wrote it at one point it was four or five pages long. And yeah, inane dialogue. But I love those kinds of conversations that people have over things. I got stopped on time taking photos, these cops in, I think it was Georgia or something, could have been Alabama, but I think it was Georgia
那两个闲逛的家伙。他们大概是16、17岁的懒汉，我想是来自杜克和克里（Duke and Kerry），类似那样的地方。可能是杜克和克里，但那是那些小地方之一……我开始笑得更厉害，觉得那太搞笑了。然后写了下来，当时有四五页长。是的，愚蠢的对话。但我喜欢人们在某些事情上进行的那些对话。有一次我拍照时被拦下了，那些警察，我想是在佐治亚州还是什么地方，可能是阿拉巴马州，但我认为是佐治亚州
and it was over there more. They pulled me over. I was taking photos of a gas station that was over here and there was a school, like a kids school, elementary school over here and there are no kids outside playing. It was just a school that was there. And I took photos of the gas station and got, and I came up and got back in my car and started driving away and they lit me up and I pulled over and there was a cop came up on the the the the the to say the word pervert. And that's what it was. I went, yeah, well, you know, you can't, like, it's like you can't, yeah, you gotta watch out for those, yeah, yeah, the perverts, yeah,
就在那边。他们把我拦下了。我正在拍一个加油站，就在这边，旁边有一所学校，像是一所小学，但外面没有孩子在玩。它只是一所学校。我拍了加油站的照片，然后回到车里开车离开，他们就亮起了警灯，我靠边停车，有个警察走过来……说“变态”这个词。就是这样。我说，是的，好吧，你知道，你不能，就像你不能，是的，你得小心那些，是的，是的，变态，是的，
you gotta watch out for the perverts. It was all about listening to the rhythm of his voice and then not finding him a dumbass, finding him kind of, you know, just a dude doing his job, but just to see how many times he could say pervert. That was good fun for an average Tuesday afternoon somewhere in Georgia. Well, yeah, I mean, you are really cracking through to a humanity of it. I mean, like like the like the Dick Graffiti, like the just kind of conversations
你得小心变态。这完全是关于倾听他声音的节奏，而不是觉得他是个笨蛋，觉得他只是个做自己工作的家伙，只是想看看他能说多少次“变态”。对于佐治亚州某个普通的周二下午来说，这很有趣。嗯，是的，我的意思是，你真的触及了它的人性。我的意思是，就像那些鸡巴涂鸦，就像那些……
that go nowhere that begin nowhere. You know, there's something that's ahead of a head of Latin professor that told me when they excavate like the bad parts of town from Rome, the archaeologists aren't really that excited because there's not anything like super impressive there But the entomologists get really excited because the graffiti is what teaches us what a lot of those words mean that we don't Like older latin dictionaries will will have a sexual term and it'll just say elude act But then in the 90s or the 2000s they would excavate something and be like, oh, that's what it is. Okay now we know Little illustration there and then now. There's a little illustration there.
无处开始也无处结束的对话。你知道，有一位拉丁语教授曾告诉我，当他们挖掘罗马那些糟糕的城镇部分时，考古学家并不是很兴奋，因为那里没有什么特别令人印象深刻的东西。但昆虫学家却非常兴奋，因为涂鸦教会了我们很多那些我们不知道的词汇的意思。比如旧的拉丁语词典会有一个性术语，它只会说“隐晦”。但在90年代或2000年代，他们挖掘出一些东西时会说，哦，原来是这个意思。好的，现在我们知道了。那里有一个小插图，然后现在。那里有一个小插图。
And then now the dictionary is a little bit more filled in from the graffiti. Well, I think that's, you know, because I call a lot of the photos to me seem like a language, the photos that I take, that there's some language that you have. And it's the language of the sort of collective aesthetic idea of that town or that area. And you have to, or I have to be able to decode that really quickly to understand lexicon. And that's what I'm doing a lot when I go across. So sometimes the language is visual with me, and then sometimes it's written. So then I write something and sometimes it's one word
然后现在词典从涂鸦中补充得更完整了。嗯，我认为这是，你知道，因为我称很多照片对我来说似乎是一种语言，我拍的照片，你拥有某种语言。它是那个城镇或地区集体审美理念的语言。你必须，或者我必须能够非常快地解码它以理解词汇。这就是我穿越时所做的大部分工作。所以有时语言对我来说是视觉的，有时是书面的。所以我写了一些东西，有时是一个词
and sometimes it needs 300 words to tell the story of this thing. And there's always, like the graffiti, there's an impression that's left, I think in that area that sometimes you can, I don't physically see it, like I'm not hallucinating or anything, but you can see that there's some lives that have passed through there and you can see what they are and you might
有时需要300个字来讲述这件事的故事。而且总是，就像涂鸦一样，我认为在那个地区留下了一种印象，有时你可以，我不是在物理上看到它，就像我没有产生幻觉什么的，但你可以看到有一些生命经过那里，你可以看到它们是什么，你可能
be wrong. But if you open up to that idea, whether there's something happening or not, but you open up to the idea of perhaps discovering a real life that walked through there. To me, that's the way to go. Yeah where they grow headstones is a beautiful photo and just such a short perfect description. Long riding. I think that's in South Carolina somewhere. Yeah I saw this building and went right swerved over to the side of the road and I passed it so I had to walk back because there were four lanes of traffic and crossed it and walked over and just took photos the the shape of it and the way it was just standing on this green grass and it had been loathed and it was so pretty and had great light on it. It was shining like this grave. Yeah,
会错。但如果你对那个想法敞开心扉，无论是否真的发生了什么，但你对可能发现一个真实生活过那里的人的想法敞开心扉。对我来说，这就是前进的方式。是的，“他们种植墓碑的地方”是一张美丽的照片，描述简短而完美。长途骑行。我想那是在南卡罗来纳州的某个地方。是的，我看到了这座建筑，立刻转向路边，我错过了它，所以我不得不走回去，因为有四条车道，我穿过它，走过去，拍了照片……它的形状，它矗立在绿草地上的方式，它被遗弃了，它太美了，光线很好。它像这座坟墓一样闪耀。是的，
that's the thing. Thanks. Yeah, that was a good one. Well, your book break is completely to my taste in art because I like the grounded abstractness and I like when the art is like very well thought out and kind of pointing you at something, but it's also just not adorned. I mean, it's almost kind of like folk art photography and it's just not, there's nothing pretentious. There's nothing like there's tons of deep thinking
就是这样。谢谢。是的，那是一张好照片。嗯，你的书完全符合我的艺术品味，因为我喜欢扎实的抽象感，我喜欢当艺术经过深思熟虑并指向某样东西时，但它也只是没有装饰。我的意思是，它几乎就像民间艺术摄影，它只是没有，没有什么矫揉造作。没有什么……虽然有大量的深度思考
and feeling and ways of being, but it's just not kind of dressed up or overly thought out. I mean, it's just like so much of that kind of just connection to a place and really like feeling, setting as so much of what I look for really in any media. And it's fantastic and so funny. Like there's the restaurant that's just called restaurant
和情感以及存在方式，但它只是没有经过修饰或过度思考。我的意思是，它就像那种与地方的联系，真的就像感觉一样，环境是我在任何媒体中真正寻找的东西。这太棒了，而且非常有趣。比如那家餐厅就叫“餐厅”
and then you imagine the conversation of the people in the restaurant. the irony would have ruined that book if there was even one photo that was ironic where I thought I was smarter than the photo or smarter than the words or any words. And I was winking to the audience like, can you believe this? These fucking hillbillies. It fell over. You can share in the wonder of that photo or the wonder of those characters or those people, you can share it, but you can't talk down to it. And that's a huge problem too, because there's so many lefty friends I have out here and I've been on the left side of the political world
然后你想象餐厅里人们的对话。如果有一张照片是讽刺的，或者我觉得我比照片或文字更聪明，那这种讽刺会毁了那本书。如果我是在对观众眨眼说，你能相信这些该死的乡巴佬吗？它就倒塌了。你可以分享那张照片的奇迹，或者那些角色或那些人的奇迹，你可以分享它，但你不能居高临下地谈论它。这是一个巨大的问题，因为我在这里有很多左派朋友，我一生都在政治世界的左翼，我将继续保持下去，但这里有很多左派朋友确信右翼的人不如他们聪明。他们只是更笨。你无法说服他们改变想法。他们不这样做，因为他们不去洛杉矶。如果他们离开洛杉矶，他们会去纽约，然后又回来。
my whole life and I will continue to be, but there's so many of my lefty friends out here that are convinced that the people on the right are just not as smart as they are. They're just dumber. And you can't talk them out of it. They don't because they don't get out of LA. And if they do get out of LA, they go to New York and then they come back.
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并）
And the same thing on the right. They're convinced that they just have a really great practical view of the world. And the lefties are fucking psychotics and just different blind spots different types of projection you know but it really is and those to me are the same people I don't know why they vote differently I think they should have both stopped voting and let the people in the middle vote I think they're avoiding different things like CNN and Fox News are selling two different kind of like easy avoidant narratives
右翼也是一样。他们确信自己对世界有非常实际的看法。而左派是该死的精神病患者，只是不同的盲点，不同类型的投射，你知道，但确实如此。对我来说，他们是同一类人，我不知道为什么他们投票不同，我认为他们都应该停止投票，让中间派投票。我认为他们都在回避不同的事情，比如CNN和福克斯新闻正在兜售两种不同的、容易回避的叙事
that don't really make you engage with each other, you know. Well, yeah, but their job is not to engage with each other. Job is to sell soap. And we think that it's a news gathering organization and it's a money gathering organization and both of them are money gathering organizations and they've just positioned themselves to rake in the most money they can from their side. So yeah, I think both of those, not to get too political here because that's the work. Well, no, that was the next question that I had written was like, you know, is the book political? Not red, blue political, but there is like a call back to just a common humanity and a way of listening without looking down. I mean, like there's there's other books like this that I don't like because the person acts like I'm going to go put my safari hat on
这并不能真正让你与对方接触，你知道。嗯，是的，但他们的工作不是互相接触。工作是卖肥皂。我们认为它是一个新闻采集组织，但它是一个金钱采集组织，两者都是金钱采集组织，他们只是将自己定位为从他们的一方尽可能多地捞钱。所以是的，我认为这两者，不是为了在这里谈论太多政治，因为那是工作。嗯，不，我写的下一个问题是，这本书是政治性的吗？不是红蓝政治，但有一种对共同人性的呼唤，以及一种不居高临下倾听的方式。我的意思是，还有其他像这样的书，我不喜欢，因为那个人表现得好像我要戴上我的狩猎帽
and go from New York into Kansas and then photograph the natives and then go back to the city. And that isn't the way that this one's written. I mean, you're really kind of embedded in these like things. And I mean, like the picture of the rock shop, it's like I could have seen that rock shop. It's so familiar. I maybe I did. And a lot of people have taken photos of it I've seen that online yeah well there's so many like it I mean it's just so much of a common you know thing
从纽约去堪萨斯，然后拍摄当地人，然后再回到城市。这不是这本书的写法。我的意思是，你真的嵌入在这些东西里。我的意思是，比如岩石商店的照片，我本可以看到那个岩石商店。它太熟悉了。也许我见过。很多人拍过它的照片，我在网上看到过，是的，嗯，有很多像它一样的东西，我的意思是，它只是一个共同的，你知道的东西
uh that it is sort of making something familiar to everybody you know whether or not we have those experiences we're kind of aware and like you said, not punching down, not looking down on anybody. The cynicism would have been the death to the heart of something like that. Yeah, it wasn't a political act on my part because I didn't want that to, in this work, I didn't want it to be anything near there.
它确实让每个人都感到熟悉，你知道，无论我们是否有这些经历，我们都有所察觉，就像你说的，不向下打击，不看不起任何人。愤世嫉俗会是这种东西核心的死亡。是的，这不是我个人的政治行为，因为我不想在作品中让它接近任何政治。
I think if anything, it might've been a, there's not a political bent, but there might be more of a spiritual bent to it, sort of an American spiritual bent, not a Godhead per se, but more this sort of collective idea we all have about what America is and be able to touch that thing and to see that thing. I think that might be that might be more of what it is to me.
我认为如果有的话，它可能是一个……没有政治倾向，但它可能更多地带有一种精神倾向，一种美国式的精神倾向，不是上帝本身，而是我们所有人对美国是什么的这种集体观念，能够触及那个东西并看到那个东西。我认为这可能更多地是它对我而言的意义。
More of a transcendence than like a, you know, mountaintop experience. I think so, like an Emersonian transcendent thing, you know, that that ideal that. There's something mountaintop about it, but the mountaintop is in the rock shop. You know, and if you can't find the mountaintop in the rock shop, I think you're in trouble. I think you have to be able to find the mountaintop in the rock shop or in the penises on the gas station. You have to be able to see that as a,
更多的是一种超越，而不是像那种山顶体验。我想是的，像爱默生式的超越，你知道，那种理想。它有一些山顶的特质，但山顶就在岩石商店里。你知道，如果你不能在岩石商店里找到山顶，我想你有麻烦了。我认为你必须能够在岩石商店里，或者在加油站的阴茎涂鸦里找到山顶。你必须能够将其视为一个，
if not a spiritual, it's not really a spiritual message, but I have to be able to, I've challenged myself to be able to find beauty in that. And the ultimate expression of that beauty, I think, is to be able to embrace all of that stuff. If it's the side of a Shoney's restaurant, it just has a weird shadow on it. And that's it. But I think that's as legitimate as, you know, taking photos of the, you know, the Louvre, taking photos in the Louvre or something, or taking photos in Paris. It's a different
如果不是精神信息，那真的不是精神信息，但我必须能够，我挑战自己能够在那里面找到美。我认为这种美的终极表达是能够拥抱所有这些东西。如果它是Shoney's餐厅的一侧，它只是上面有一个奇怪的阴影。就是这样。但我认为这和拍摄卢浮宫，或者在巴黎拍照一样合法。这是一种不同的
aesthetics. But I think- Well, we've seen that photo before. We haven't seen your photos. I mean, like, you have the same street in Paris, you know, like, how many times has that been photographed the I don't know if you've ever been, but it's kind of in the desert and it's got giant, super flat, there's some mountains right on the edge. And it's just a basin and today it'll be 104 degrees there and it'll be 82 in LA. And it's ruthless, it's a ruthless town and there's a lot of one story buildings because anything over that costs too much to air condition. And there's 800,000 or a million square foot warehouses where they make airplanes and airplane wings
审美。但我认为——嗯，我们以前见过那张照片。我们没见过你的照片。我的意思是，你在巴黎有同一条街道，你知道，那被拍过多少次了……我不知道你是否去过，但它有点在沙漠里，它有巨大的、超级平坦的，边缘有一些山。它只是一个盆地，今天那里会有104度，而洛杉矶是82度。这是一个无情的城镇，有很多单层建筑，因为任何超过这个高度的建筑空调成本都太高了。那里有80万或100万平方英尺的仓库，他们在那里制造飞机和飞机机翼
and McDonald Douglas and Skunk Works and shit out there. So I thought taking photos out there years ago, it was hot, it was in August, it was just wasted. You really have to drink a gallon of water while you're driving around there during the day. If you're getting in and out of your car car taking photographs like a dummy. And I was taking photos and thought this is this is not a pretty town. This is an ugly town. I thought boy a kid growing up here and you know Christmas time and this is his Christmas. They drive
还有麦道公司和臭鼬工厂之类的东西。所以我几年前在那里拍照，天气很热，是在八月，简直是浪费。你在白天开车时真的必须喝一加仑水。如果你像个傻瓜一样进出车里拍照。我当时在拍照，心想这不是一个漂亮的城镇。这是一个丑陋的城镇。我想，天哪，一个在这里长大的孩子，你知道，圣诞节的时候，这就是他的圣诞节。他们开车
down the street and they pass the 800,000 square foot fiberglass building where they make jets. And the kid gets to see that, and it's just a gray building with a white strip going through. And I thought, well, that's ugly as hell. As in my hometown, little town, Marshalltown, Iowa, beautiful little downtown there, old brick buildings built.
经过街道，经过他们制造喷气式飞机的80万平方英尺的玻璃纤维建筑。孩子能看到那个，它只是一个中间有一条白条的灰色建筑。我想，那真是丑得要命。而在我的家乡，爱荷华州的小镇马歇尔敦，那里有一个美丽的市中心，建造了古老的砖砌建筑。
And I mean, before the tornado hit it a few years ago, kind of fucked up that town. That town's been fucked up a number of times, but regardless, when I was a kid in the 60s and 70s, it was beautiful. And I thought, well, that's a beautiful downtown in the winter for Christmas time with snow coming in. And I thought, well, wait a minute,
我的意思是，在几年前龙卷风袭击它之前，那种把那个城镇搞得一团糟。那个城镇已经被搞砸了好几次，但无论如何，当我在60年代和70年代还是个孩子时，它很美。我想，那是一个美丽的市中心，在圣诞节的时候，雪花飘落。我想，等一下，
not to bang on Paris, but some kid growing up in Paris looks at my hometown and Marshalltown and goes, what a dump, you gotta grow up in that. Oh, it's just a measure of your aesthetic to what your visual aesthetic that you grow up in. And that kid in Palmdale looks at that building and he sees some beauty there. He knows that it's not Rome.
不是要抨击巴黎，但一些在巴黎长大的孩子看着我的家乡和马歇尔敦，会说，真是个垃圾场，你竟然在那种地方长大。哦，这只是你对你成长过程中的视觉审美的衡量。帕姆代尔的那个孩子看着那座建筑，他在那里看到了一些美。他知道那不是罗马。
He knows that. He knows that it's not Fouquet. He knows what the story is, but he finds joy in that and it informs his visual aesthetic. And I thought, well, can I change my visual aesthetic to find that town beautiful and towns like it beautiful and these liminal places that are like that? Can I find that beauty? Can I find beauty in that? And that's what sent me on this whole kind of journey. Well, yeah, so much of your book is like the photographs of like the side of a building or the back of a building or the exit doors. But then there is a personality and a story that comes from, you know, somebody was painting and they made a mistake, and then they tried to do it, and then they didn't do it right right or they put this here or, you know, just this, you know, not the, so much personality in the exit door,
他知道。他知道那不是富凯（Fouquet）。他知道故事是什么，但他从中找到了快乐，它塑造了他的视觉审美。我想，我能改变我的视觉审美来发现那个城镇的美，以及像它一样的城镇的美，还有这些像那样的边缘地带吗？我能找到那种美吗？我能在那里面找到美吗？这就是让我踏上整个旅程的原因。嗯，是的，你的书里有很多照片，比如建筑的一侧，或者建筑的背面，或者出口门。但随后有一种个性和故事，来自，你知道，有人在画画，他们犯了一个错误，然后他们试图去做，然后他们没有做对，或者他们把这个放在这里，或者，你知道，只是这个，你知道，不是那个，出口门里有太多的个性，
you know, it's really interesting. Do you, what are you shooting on? Do you think about equipment too much? Is the technical bit not really the point for you or? Technical bits never been the point for me. There's guys who know a lot more about cameras than I do and love shooting on film. the the And you know, it has to, for me, it's all about the story. And I guess there's technically good photographers, but if they're not telling a story, then no one cares.
你知道，这真的很有趣。你，你在用什么拍摄？你是否太在意设备了？技术部分对你来说真的不是重点吗？技术部分对我来说从来都不是重点。有些人比我更了解相机，喜欢用胶片拍摄。……你知道，对我来说，一切都是关于故事。我想有技术上很好的摄影师，但如果他们不讲故事，那么没人会在意。
I mean, really, a friend of mine sent me a photo from, he just started taking photos and I encouraged him. And he sent me some photos of a homeless dude in New York. And he took photos of a dude on the street. And he was an African-American guy. And he had some tears tattooed in his face and some other lightning bolts. This is a rough time in life.
我的意思是，真的，我的一个朋友给我发了一张照片，他刚开始拍照，我鼓励了他。他给我发了一些纽约一个无家可归者的照片。他在街上拍了一个人。他是一个非裔美国人。他的脸上纹了一些眼泪和其他闪电。这是生命中艰难的时刻。
And he said, hey, what about these? How are these? And he sent me two photos of the guy. And I thought, what are you doing? Why are you, why did you wake up and take photos of anything today? Do you know why you took photos of the thing? You have to ask yourself that and is it the right medium? If you want to write a play, maybe a play is the right thing for this. You see filmmakers all the time just desperate to make films and so many films I see I go well that would be a great short story.
他说，嘿，这些怎么样？这些如何？他给我发了两张那个人的照片。我想，你在做什么？为什么你，你今天为什么要醒来拍任何东西？你知道你为什么要拍那个东西吗？你必须问自己，这是正确的媒介吗？如果你想写一部戏，也许戏是这件事的正确选择。你总是看到电影制作人拼命想拍电影，我看到的很多电影，我心想，那会是一个很棒的短篇小说。
It's not a film. It'd be a great short story or a cool sculpture. You could make that into a sculpture but you decided to use film. I don't know why. People don't ever question the medium they use. And for me I have this camera in my hand and I'm always asking myself why are you taking a photo of that? What are you doing? What are you doing here in a little town in Oklahoma, you know, in July taking a photo of that dog with a weird leg? Why are you doing that? I can always answer it, you know. I have to answer it. It's my job to be able to answer it to myself, not to you or anyone else, but I have to be able to answer it. Like when I was younger, there was this company, Walden Books, Walden Bookstore,
这不是电影。那会是一个很棒的短篇小说或很酷的雕塑。你可以把它做成雕塑，但你决定使用电影。我不知道为什么。人们从不质疑他们使用的媒介。对我来说，我手里拿着这个相机，我总是问自己，你为什么要拍那个？你在做什么？你在俄克拉荷马州的一个小镇，你知道，在七月，拍那只腿奇怪的狗在做什么？你为什么要那样做？我总是能回答它，你知道。我必须回答它。我的工作是能够回答它，不是对你或任何人，但我必须能够回答它。就像我年轻的时候，有这家公司，Walden Books，Walden书店，
that if you couldn't get a Barnes and Noble or couldn't get a legit bookstore in your town, you got a Walden Books in your mall. In Marshalltown, we had a mall, we had a Walden Books. And they had a few books, a lot of romance novels, and a couple of bestsellers, but nothing really great. But it was the only access to a bookstore we had. And there was of course, no Amazon.
如果你在你的城镇里找不到巴诺书店（Barnes and Noble）或合法的书店，你的商场里就有Walden Books。在马歇尔敦，我们有一个商场，我们有一个Walden Books。他们有一些书，很多浪漫小说，还有几本畅销书，但没有什么真正伟大的东西。但那是我们唯一能接触到的书店。当然，没有亚马逊。
And they would always have knickknacks and mugs and coffee cups and things. And they had calendars. And every year there'd be an Iowa barn calendar. Oh, Iowa barns. Oh, look at that barn there. Oh, it's a barn up on a hill. Look at it in the sunrise.
他们总是有小饰品、马克杯、咖啡杯之类的东西。他们有日历。每年都会有一本爱荷华州谷仓日历。哦，爱荷华州的谷仓。哦，看那个谷仓。哦，它是一个山上的谷仓。看它在日出时的样子。
Oh, look at the way the sunrise hits that barn. It'd be a Look at the sunrise. Oh, look at the way the sunrise hits that barn. It be a beautiful barn and sunrise. Okay. Yeah. Then you go to, you know, October. Oh, look at the leaves fell around the barn. Oh, beautiful at
哦，看日出照在那个谷仓上的方式。那会是一个……看日出。哦，看日出照在那个谷仓上的方式。那会是一个美丽的谷仓和日出。好的。是的。然后你去，你知道，十月。哦，看叶子落在谷仓周围。哦，在日落时很美。
sunset. The leaves, the orange leaves around the barn and years later, I was taking photos of a barn out in Iowa and it struck me. I remembered that calendar and I went, what the fuck are you doing taking photos at sunset? What has happened? What's going on? Yeah. Why am I taking this photo of a barn? Because it looks, why does it look cool? Because it's bathed in this sort of orangey yellow light. But what are you adding anything to the discussion about Barnes? No. Are you adding anything to the aesthetic idea about Iowa Barnes? No. Well, then why the fuck you taking a photo of an Iowa barn?
日落时，谷仓周围橙色的叶子，多年后，我正在爱荷华州拍一个谷仓，它打动了我。我记得那个日历，我心想，你他妈在日落时拍什么照片？发生了什么？怎么回事？是的。我为什么要拍这个谷仓的照片？因为它看起来，为什么它看起来很酷？因为它沐浴在这种橙黄色的光线下。但你对关于谷仓的讨论增加了任何东西吗？没有。你对爱荷华州谷仓的审美理念增加了任何东西吗？没有。好吧，那你他妈为什么要拍爱荷华州谷仓的照片？
What are you adding to this conversation? And I was adding nothing. And I thought, well, maybe I need to take photos of things that I can either start a conversation with or add to a conversation. So this is the area that I can either start a conversation with or add to a conversation. So this is the area that I chose. Like it's the same thing goes for guys taking photos of nude women. Like good, I guess, but what are you doing?
你对这个对话增加了什么？我什么也没增加。我想，也许我需要拍一些我可以开始对话或增加对话的东西。所以这是我可以开始对话或增加对话的领域。所以这是我选择的领域。就像男人拍裸体女人的照片一样，比如好，我猜，但你在做什么？
You just found a different girl to pose nude for you? Like what the fuck is the point of this one? Oh, you lit her differently with shadow? Ooh, look at that. Oh, she's not super sexy, she's kind of big. Okay, we've seen that. Like all of it's been done, which doesn't mean you shouldn't do it, but.
你只是找到了另一个女孩为你拍裸照？这他妈有什么意义？哦，你用阴影以不同的方式照亮了她？哦，看看那个。哦，她不是超级性感，她有点胖。好的，我们见过那个。就像所有这些都已经做过了，这并不意味着你不应该做，但是。
But why are you doing it? What of you personally are you adding to the conversation? Are you just being another dude taking photos of barns and nudes? Or are you adding something? Are you looking at this in a different way? And that's what I've tried to do with these, is look at the world that I saw in,
但你为什么要这样做？你个人对这个对话增加了什么？你只是另一个拍谷仓和裸照的男人吗？还是你增加了什么？你以不同的方式看待这个吗？这就是我试图用这些照片做的事情，是看待我所看到的世界，
not necessarily a different way, but it was a way that I started to, it was a vein of aesthetics that I started to mine, and I'm still kind of mining it. Well, and it looks like the things that you would have seen growing up in the 60s through the 80s on a road trip, like it looks like the things that you would have seen growing up in the 60s to the 80s on a road trip. It looks like when you look out the window as you're going from town to town.
不一定是不同的方式，但这是我开始的一种方式，它是我开始挖掘的一种审美脉络，我仍然在挖掘它。嗯，看起来就像你在60年代到80年代公路旅行中会看到的东西，就像你在60年代到80年代公路旅行中会看到的东西。看起来就像你从一个城镇到另一个城镇时向窗外看的样子。
I think my dad and a lot of people of my dad's generation, they just love to get the family in the car and go for a long trip for a couple days and just see the countryside. You really would just come to this spot, you come to the next spot. The book feels like a road trip. There's a Paris the in that direction really. It just hasn't, I haven't pursued it and it hasn't popped up in my in my vision but it might soon. We'll see what happens. Well you're acting like a lot of the roles that I love, Halt and Catch Fire. It's one of my favorite shows of all time. I mean to me it's up there with Mad Men and the Sopranos in like a different way just because there's something about watching history happen and then repeat itself and watching technology kind of reflect emotional needs. And I mean, there's I always try and get people to watch it and tell them like, this is just this is about computers in the same way that the hustler is about pool. You know, exactly. Jumping off point. Yeah.
我想我父亲和我父亲那一代的很多人，他们只是喜欢把家人带上车，去长途旅行几天，看看乡村。你真的会来到这个点，你来到下一个点。这本书感觉像是一次公路旅行。那个方向确实有一个巴黎。只是我还没有追求它，它还没有出现在我的视野中，但它可能很快就会出现。我们看看会发生什么。嗯，你表现得像我喜欢的很多角色，比如《奔腾年代》。这是我最喜欢的节目之一。我的意思是，对我来说，它和《广告狂人》（Mad Men）和《黑道家族》（The Sopranos）处于同一水平，只是以一种不同的方式，因为看着历史发生然后重复，看着技术反映情感需求，这很有意思。我的意思是，我总是试图让人们看它，并告诉他们，这就像《江湖浪子》（The Hustler）是关于台球一样，是关于计算机的。你知道，没错。跳板。是的。
Examination of the thing that gets you to the thing. But sure. I mean, that role, a lot of roles, you have kind of a folksy, not quite con artists, but putting on a performance that maybe you're not aware of, putting on a performance that you're not putting on a performance is like the kind of Toby Hus thing when you're like, what was his, there's kind of a like a carnival barker,
对让你达到那个东西的东西的审视。但当然。我的意思是，那个角色，很多角色，你有一种民间风格，不是完全的骗子，但进行了一种你可能没有意识到的表演，进行了一种你没有进行表演的表演，这就像托比·哈斯（Toby Huss）的东西，当你像，他的是什么，有一种像嘉年华叫卖者，
showman folksy, getting people's confidence, not always for the wrong reasons. I mean, how much of that is you or how much of that is, and maybe I'm totally misreading the performance, but is that, could you say anything about that? Well, let me understand what you're saying, that I'm choosing to portray the character in a, that has sort of two facets or that I'm projecting a thing onto it. No, well, I don't know exactly how it ends up there, but what I see a lot is like a character that's kind of doing a performance of not doing a performance, you know, trying to make people feel comfortable, trying to make people feel at ease, but also sort of in a way that not necessarily
表演者民间风格，获得人们的信任，并不总是出于错误的原因。我的意思是，其中有多少是你，或者其中有多少是，也许我完全误读了表演，但那是，你能对此说点什么吗？嗯，让我理解你在说什么，我选择以一种有两个侧面的方式来描绘角色，或者我正在向它投射一个东西。不，嗯，我不知道它最终是怎么到那里的，但我看到很多的是一个角色，他正在进行一种不做表演的表演，你知道，试图让人们感到舒服，试图让人们感到自在，但也以一种不一定
and manipulative in a bad way all the time, but is kind of trying to be folksy to put people at ease to sell something to, I don't know. I mean, do you? I think some of the things are possibly that, but it's not that, it's not as direct as that. It's much more opaque. And I think sometimes people fall into these kind of modes of behavior that are performative. And I think sometimes Bosworth, like in the Halt and Catch Fire, he needed to be performative because he was a salesman, a real timey salesman. So that is a lot of performance. But then back off like the scenes I had with McKenzie Davis, when he'd back off and talk to Cameron like a human, I think that would get dropped. And then through his, through the arc of the whole
一直以坏的方式操纵，但试图变得民间化以让人们感到自在，以卖掉什么东西，我不知道。我的意思是，你吗？我想有些事情可能是那样，但它不像那样直接。它更不透明。我认为有时人们会陷入这种表演性的行为模式。我认为有时博斯沃思（Bosworth），就像在《奔腾年代》中，他需要表演，因为他是一个推销员，一个真正的推销员。所以那有很多表演。但后来退后，就像我和麦肯齐·戴维斯（Mackenzie Davis）的场景，当他退后并像人类一样与卡梅伦（Cameron）交谈时，我认为那会被丢弃。然后通过整个
seasons, you saw this guy kind of get crushed under the weight of how he was before and how we were before his old technology physical technology cbs and radios and such and then his old kind of performative behavior and toward the end he lost all that shit and he was this he sort of became a different version of himself i mean all the characters are very stripped down by the end of that I mean, I'm really glad that that show got the last season because it slows it down. Yeah best way But I mean I guess kind of what I mean is when Bosworth it is at his most Performative when he's really trying to sell something to the Texans or get into the room It's on like, you know, that is a performance that is a sale, but it's like the exact same energy as the most raw and
季节的弧线，你看到这个家伙被他以前的样子和他以前的技术物理技术CBS和收音机等所压垮，然后他以前的那种表演行为，到最后他失去了所有那些狗屎，他成为了一个不同版本的自己，我的意思是所有角色到最后都被剥离了。我的意思是，我真的很高兴那个节目有最后一季，因为它放慢了速度。是的，最好的方式。但我的意思是，我猜我的意思是，当博斯沃思处于他最表演的时候，当他真的试图向德克萨斯人推销什么东西或进入房间时，它就像，你知道，那是一种表演，那是一种销售，但它就像最原始和
earnest moments like when Cameron pushes the IPO and Bosworth is like, you're breaking my fucking heart, or yeah, the radio at the very end, where he's like, I'm going to live to the 20th century. It's like, it's the same thing. When it's the you know, the the the the sale and and the person I don't know that it's a really great- Well, he was that kind of a guy, and I thought, to me, it didn't make him,
最真诚的时刻一样的能量，比如当卡梅伦推动IPO而博斯沃思说，你正在伤我的心，或者是的，最后的收音机，他说，我要活到20世纪。这就像，是一样的。当它是你知道，销售和人……我不知道那是一个非常伟大的……嗯，他就是那种家伙，我想，对我来说，这并没有让他，
to me, that was his authenticity too. There are people who were, I mean, maybe he wasn't really a born salesman, but there was something in him that drew him to that way of living and that way of life and that way of kind of constructing his personality, I thought. And I know sale, I have a cousin who's a salesman has been, he's, he's that guy in his real life,
对我来说，那也是他的真实性。有些人，我的意思是，也许他不是一个天生的推销员，但我认为他身上有什么东西吸引他去那种生活方式，那种生活方式，以及那种构建他个性的方式。我知道销售，我有一个表弟是推销员，他就是他现实生活中的那个人，
whether he's talking about his, his kids or whether he's talking about, you know, getting cut in on a $4 million deal that he's doing for a software company. He's got that kind of energy and it's, it's now part of him. He turns it up a notch when he goes in for a sale and when I hear him on the phone. But he's kind of that guy. And I think Bosworth is that kind of a guy. I think that animal, some animals need, the way that I've run into people in my lives that need a certain level of chaos to feel engaged in life and to feel that they're alive when they're dealing with this chaos and it makes them feel like their life has value and they have worth. So they need to keep this chaos going.
无论他是在谈论他的孩子，还是在谈论他正在为一家软件公司进行的400万美元交易。他有那种能量，现在它是他的一部分。当他去销售时，当我听到他在电话里时，他会把它调高一个档次。但他就是那种家伙。我认为博斯沃思就是那种家伙。我认为那种动物，我在生活中遇到过需要一定程度的混乱才能感到参与生活，并感到他们还活着的人，当他们处理这种混乱时，这让他们觉得他们的生活有价值，他们有价值。所以他们需要保持这种混乱。
And if they can't find a way to turn a situation chaotic, then they would draw and they're unhappy and they're awful. And I think maybe in an almost similar way Bosworth was a little bit like that. Like he had to be cutting a deal somehow, whether it was with Cameron or whether it was with Joe or whether it was with his own conscience and his divorce and that sort of thing. He couldn't keep it going because that's the way that guy felt engaged. He did a lot, you know, toward the end of the season, it was like three and four. He did become engaged in a real different way. Like even when, you know, Scoot goes away, you know, even when Gordon goes away, he's
如果他们找不到制造混乱的方法，他们就会感到沮丧、不开心，甚至表现得很糟糕。我觉得博斯沃思（Bosworth）在某种程度上也有点像这样。他似乎总得达成某种交易，无论是与卡梅伦（Cameron）、乔（Joe），还是与他自己的良心、他的离婚等等。他无法停止这种状态，因为这就是他感到自己投入其中的方式。在第一季和第四季快结束时，他确实以一种非常不同的方式投入其中。即使在斯科特（Scoot）离开，甚至戈登（Gordon）离开之后，他依然
engaging what he's making to Chile. He's engaging everyone. The sentiment in the Chile is really great. He's selling the idea of love and care and community to these people and compassion. He he's taking care of in the way that he knows how It's really delicately ridden those things Look King of the Hills coming back are you on them on the re reboot of that one? Are you gonna be voice acting for it? Yeah Yeah, they con is gonna be played I'm not playing con anymore. Yes
他正在投入他为智利所做的事情。他正在与每个人互动。智利的情绪真的很棒。他向这些人兜售爱、关怀、社区和同情心的理念。他以他所知的方式照顾着他们。这些事情处理得非常微妙。嘿，《山丘之王》（King of the Hill）要回归了，你参与了那个重启版吗？你会为它配音吗？是的，是的，康（Kahn）这个角色将会由……我不再扮演康了。是的。
Con is going to be played. I'm not playing Con anymore. Yes. They're just not going to do that. But I did a cotton in a few episodes in flashbacks. But then I took over the voice of Dale cause Johnny Hardwick passed away. I mean, like two years ago now. And he was a buddy and I did it a couple of times
康这个角色将会由别人来演。我不再扮演康了。是的。他们只是不打算那样做了。但我确实在几集的闪回中扮演了科顿（Cotton）。后来我接手了戴尔（Dale）的配音，因为约翰尼·哈德威克（Johnny Hardwick）去世了。我的意思是，那大概是两年前的事了。他是个好哥们，我替他配过几次
or read throughs and they were gonna maybe AI the voice or get someone else to do it and they said, why don't you just do it? Okay, that's great. It was really humbling that they asked me to play Johnny and it's really heartfelt stuff. Yeah, cause you can't, it's funny, like when I bring up Bosworth,
或者读过剧本，他们本来可能打算用人工智能来合成声音，或者找别人来做，但他们说，为什么你不直接来配呢？好吧，那太棒了。他们让我扮演约翰尼让我感到非常谦卑，这真的是发自内心的。是的，因为你不能……很有趣，就像我提到博斯沃思时，
there's one time when I do, okay, sorry, the wardrobe lady, she said, Hey, we're going to get you some cowboy boots to wear. I'm fine because I was asking for them. So they got 12 pairs of cowboy boots and they lined them up. And they said, all right, which one? And she said, I was thinking about these. And I went, those are his boots over here. And I picked the boots and he went, well, these are, I said, no, no, no, no, no, none. I understand me. I pick the right boots every time. You're very good at what you do.
有一次，抱歉，服装师说，嘿，我们要给你找双牛仔靴穿。我说行，因为我本来就在找。于是他们拿来了12双牛仔靴排成一排。他们说，好了，选哪双？她说，我在考虑这双。我说，那是他的靴子，在这边。我挑了那双靴子，他说，嗯，这些是……我说，不不不，不，你不明白。我每次都能挑对靴子。你真的很擅长你的工作。
And they're great wardrobe people on that show, but I have to feel that when I'm playing a character, I know more about the character than anyone. And chances are I do. And it's not your character anymore. It's fucking my character. So the, when I was doing Cotton on King of the Hill, it just so happens their writing was so good, or like with Halt and Catch Fire,
那个剧组的服装人员很棒，但我必须感觉到，当我在扮演一个角色时，我比任何人都更了解这个角色。而且很有可能我确实了解。那不再是你的角色了，那是他妈的我的角色。所以，当我在《山丘之王》里扮演科顿的时候，碰巧他们的剧本写得非常好，就像《奔腾年代》（Halt and Catch Fire）一样，
the writing was so good. We agreed on what the character was gonna do 99.9% of the time, but that last, you know, 0.01%, that's me. And I know what that character is. So when I went to do Dale's voice, because I'm the expert on that character, so I went to do Dale's voice. I did it and I can sound like Johnny well enough.
剧本写得太好了。我们对角色99.9%的行为达成了一致，但最后那0.01%，那是我。我知道那个角色是什么样的。所以当我去做戴尔的配音时，因为我是那个角色的专家，所以我去做了。我做到了，而且我模仿约翰尼的声音模仿得足够像。
We probably smoked the same amount of cigarettes over our lives. Well, he doesn't smoke anymore and I don't smoke anymore either, but he was a really unique, wonderful guy. Johnny was with a really interesting take on his character. He didn't start out as an actor. He started out as a as a standup.
我们这辈子抽的烟数量可能差不多。好吧，他现在不抽烟了，我也不抽了，但他是一个非常独特、很棒的人。约翰尼对他的角色有非常有趣的诠释。他起初并不是演员。他最初是一名脱口秀演员。
And he was also just a wonderful goofball and a sweetheart and a nut. So he had these really other takes on lines that were just great and weird boys. OK, you can never get that out of AI. the When I did it, I did his voice and I got close enough and I thought, this sounds like Johnny, that's enough, sounds like Dale. But I'm never going to be the expert on that character the way that I was the expert on Boz or someone else because the expert on that character passed away. Johnny's not here. So he's the expert on Dale.
他也是个很棒的傻瓜、甜心和怪人。所以他对台词有一些非常独特的解读，真的很棒，而且很古怪。好吧，你永远无法从人工智能那里得到这些。当我做的时候，我模仿了他的声音，我模仿得足够接近，我想，这听起来像约翰尼，这就够了，听起来像戴尔。但我永远不会成为那个角色的专家，就像我曾经是博斯或其他角色的专家那样，因为那个角色的专家已经去世了。约翰尼不在了。所以他是戴尔的专家。
He took that with him. And that's the end of the story. So all I can do is try to honor his idea of Dale and try to be there emotionally and hopefully vocally as close as I can to that guy. So you look for creatives that are going to be more kind of actors, directors, and even let the intuition kind of inform the role instead of their vision or their kind of preconceived idea of what a character is? Is it, do I... Do you look for directors that are more of an actor's director,
他把那个带走了。故事到此为止。所以我能做的就是努力尊重他对戴尔的构想，并努力在情感上，希望在声音上尽可能地接近那个人。所以你寻找的创意人员是那种更偏向演员、导演的人，甚至让他们用直觉来引导角色，而不是用他们的愿景或对角色的先入之见？是这样吗……你寻找的是那种更懂演员的导演吗？
that let the actor bring the intuition into the role? I don't really look for directors so much as, you get a project or something's offered to you and you look at it and go, who's this guy? Okay, I don't know. We'll jump in there and see what happens. So it's always different. I'm always amenable to that.
那种让演员把直觉带入角色的导演？我其实并没有刻意寻找什么样的导演，通常是你接到了一个项目，或者有人向你提议，你看了看，然后想，这家伙是谁？好吧，我不知道。我们会跳进去看看会发生什么。所以情况总是不同的。我总是乐于接受这一点。
I just shot, worked with a really great director in Boston shooting this thing. And I hadn't worked with him before, but I knew his work. I really liked what he did. And he was super easy to get along with him, really great. And came about it from an angle that I'd never thought of. And it's just, it's so nice to get opened up to someone you've never really worked with before and find,
我刚在波士顿拍了一部戏，和一位非常棒的导演合作。我以前没和他合作过，但我了解他的作品。我真的很喜欢他所做的一切。他非常容易相处，真的很棒。他从一个我从未想过的角度切入。能向你从未真正合作过的人敞开心扉，并发现……
oh yeah, I never thought about working like that, that's great. You know, as I think, part of my job is to, you know, know my lines and stand in the right spot, but part of it is to be open to somebody else's idea and somebody else's vision and somebody else's words and define like the same way that I find beauty in those photos. I have to start with the fact that it's beautiful and then understand it. So I got to start with the fact that this man or this woman knows what they're doing
哦，是的，我从没想过那样工作，那太棒了。你知道，我认为我的工作一部分是背好台词，站在正确的位置，但另一部分是对别人的想法、别人的愿景和别人的文字保持开放，并定义它，就像我在那些照片中发现美一样。我必须从它很美这个事实开始，然后去理解它。所以我必须从这个男人或女人知道他们在做什么这个事实开始，
and let's go forward, this is great. So when you, and you've done stage stuff too. So when you do voice acting, when you do film acting, when you do your voice acting, stage acting, play acting, is there anything that is kind of different or you just kind of go in and the same process for any of them of them of finding the character. Yeah, the processes are just so different.
然后继续前进，这太棒了。所以当你……你也做过舞台剧。那么当你做配音、电影表演，当你做配音、舞台表演、戏剧表演时，有什么不同的地方吗？还是说你只是进去，对他们中的任何一个都采用同样的寻找角色的过程？是的，过程确实非常不同。
If it's a film, it's a finite amount of time. And the luxury of something like Halt or carnival is you're living with this character month after month while you're shooting. You have a lot of time to get into it. And the same thing with the stage thing. You have a lot of time to investigate that character. And you can investigate it too with a film. And sometimes you watch your films afterwards and go, well, okay, you did something there.
如果是电影，时间是有限的。而像《奔腾年代》或《嘉年华》（Carnival）这样的剧集的奢侈之处在于，你在拍摄期间月复一月地与这个角色生活在一起。你有足够的时间去深入了解它。舞台剧也是一样。你有足够的时间去研究那个角色。你也可以在电影中研究它。有时你事后看自己的电影会想，好吧，你在那里做了一些事情。
It might not have been what you really would have done if you had lived with that character for six more weeks, but it's still okay. Through the process, a little bit different. Yeah. And you paint too. I mean, do you still paint or was that something else? Yeah.
那可能不是如果你和那个角色多生活六周后会做出的选择，但那也没关系。通过这个过程，有一点不同。是的。而且你也画画。我的意思是，你还在画画吗？还是那是别的东西？是的。
So what, can you talk about that process? Or, I mean, I've read, I think, two interviews in the past where you talked about painting as kind of a way to heal trauma or be engaged with the body. And I don't know if that was it was something that had popped up in one of the interviews that I'd read by you. Yeah, I did. I had a solo show a couple of years ago in L.A.
那么，你能谈谈那个过程吗？或者，我的意思是，我读过过去的两篇采访，你谈到绘画是一种治愈创伤或与身体互动的方式。我不知道这是否是我读过的你的一篇采访中提到的东西。是的，我确实提到了。几年前我在洛杉矶举办过一个个人展览，
of these of these kind of line paintings that I'd been working on. And I come to a crossroads a couple of years before that show and I went, well, I don't know what I'm gonna do. And then I ran into this woman who was a mom at my daughter's school and she had a gallery. I went, unless she said, yeah, you wanna do something? I said, yeah, sure. So standing in front of a canvas,
展出的是我一直在创作的这种线条画。在那个展览的前几年，我到了一个十字路口，我想，好吧，我不知道我该做什么。然后我遇到了一个女人，她是我女儿学校的一位妈妈，她经营着一家画廊。我说，除非她说，是的，你想做点什么吗？我说，是的，当然。于是站在画布前，
not knowing what I was gonna do. And for a long time, I'd been drawing this kind of squiggly line that I would draw it on envelopes of letters that I typed to friends for 40 years. And I'd do it on pieces of paper. Anybody that ever lived with me over the years, oh yeah, I remember those scraps of paper that had these little lines on them,
不知道我要做什么。很长一段时间以来，我一直在画这种蜿蜒的线条，我会在我给朋友写的信的信封上画，我这样做了40年。我会在纸片上画。多年来和我住在一起的任何人都会说，哦，是的，我记得那些上面有这些小线条的纸片，
these little squiggly things. I went, yeah, listen and I had kind of realized I'd been doing it, but not really. It was pretty unconscious. And then, about, before the painting, about five years, I've been painting for, you know, 20, 30 years around,
这些小小的蜿蜒的东西。我说，是的，听着，我意识到我一直在做这件事，但并没有真正意识到。这相当无意识。然后，在大约绘画之前，大约五年，我已经画了，你知道，20、30年左右，
just on my own. And, but I started some MDMA sessions, some therapeutic MDMA sessions with a guy in New York. You know, been researching that a lot. And then, you know, when you go through that stuff, I don't know if you've ever experienced something like that, but it's pretty.
只是我自己画。但是，我开始了一些MDMA疗程，一些与纽约的一个人进行的治疗性MDMA疗程。你知道，一直在研究那个。然后，你知道，当你经历那些事情时，我不知道你是否经历过类似的事情，但这非常……
Was it helpful? We work with, I'm a social worker by license, so we help prepare people for either doing MDMA or IV ketamine or psilocybin sometimes and then they come back but they you know it's more of a preparatory thing we can't administer it. Right the MDMA stuff is pretty profound I found it to be but I haven't done you know IVA gain or I did Ayahuasca down in Costa Rica a couple summers ago. That was pretty profound as well. But the MDMA therapeutic process was releasing a lot of
有帮助吗？我们与……我是一名持证社会工作者，所以我们帮助人们准备进行MDMA、静脉注射氯胺酮或有时是裸盖菇素，然后他们回来，但你知道，这更多是一种准备工作，我们不能管理它。是的，MDMA的东西非常深刻，我发现确实如此，但我没有做过，你知道，伊博格碱（Iboga），或者我在几年前的夏天在哥斯达黎加做过死藤水（Ayahuasca）。那也非常深刻。但MDMA治疗过程释放了很多
stored trauma I found and man, it was good. But then I, you know, I was, I was standing in front of this canvas and remembering those lines started squiggling this line. I went, this is not a legitimate way to make a painting. To me, it didn't seem like a legit. I went, that's not a lot. It's not the beginning of a painting. That's just you do. Well, can that be enough? And I didn't know if it could be enough or not. And well, you have to explore that because you're feeling it in your body. So I had to. So I started painting like that. I went, son of a bitch, this is looking like a thing. This feels right. And I kept going and my body kept going and adding color and adding things to it. And I painted a lot of big canvases like that. And I think there was a physicalized trail. It seems
我发现的储存的创伤，天哪，那感觉真好。但我，你知道，我当时站在那块画布前，记起了那些线条，开始蜿蜒地画这条线。我想，这不是一种合法的绘画方式。对我来说，这看起来不合法。我想，那不是很多。那不是一幅画的开始。那只是你做的。好吧，那足够了吗？我不知道它是否足够。好吧，你必须探索它，因为你在身体里感受到了它。所以我必须这样做。所以我开始那样画画。我想，该死，这看起来像个东西。这感觉是对的。我继续画，我的身体继续画，添加颜色，添加东西。我画了很多像那样的大画布。我想有一个物理化的轨迹。这似乎
to me, speaking of language and lexicon and following those signs, that this line that I've been drawing for 40 years that had been appearing in my life for 50 years almost, that that was connected to, had a real squiggly line connection directly to some childhood from childhood trauma that I've been working through MDMA sessions. And some guy at 89.3 in L.A. didn't did an interview with me and he made like the headline of the article about he's working with childhood trauma. And I was like, well, that's kind of a little bit cheap. But I get it. He had to call it. Well, that's what I was going to call the title of the podcast.
对我来说，说到语言和词汇以及跟随那些迹象，我画了40年的这条线，在我的生活中出现了近50年，它与……与我通过MDMA疗程正在处理的一些童年创伤有直接的蜿蜒联系。洛杉矶89.3电台的一个家伙采访了我，他把文章的标题写成关于他正在处理童年创伤。我当时想，嗯，那有点廉价。但我明白了。他必须给它起个名字。好吧，那正是我要给播客起的标题。
Exactly. I feel the childhood trauma by doing a bunch of shit. the in New York, I was just there with this guy. It was my ninth session in the last five, let's see, it's 25, so six years, yeah, six years I've been doing it. But it wasn't to find childhood trauma useful. I wasn't going about it like that. I wasn't intentionally using it as fuel or a tool or it's just that you can tap into a reaction to it. It was really the examination of that stuff and how it's been physicalized in my body and how my body was releasing it. And it's going to be on your own or is going to release it with a paint brush or a camera flick or in a character or something.
没错。我通过做一堆破事来感受童年创伤。在纽约，我刚和那个家伙在一起。这是我在过去五年里的第九次疗程，让我们看看，是25，所以六年，是的，我已经做了六年了。但并不是为了发现童年创伤很有用。我不是那样做的。我不是故意把它当作燃料或工具，只是你可以利用对它的反应。这真的是对那些东西的检查，以及它是如何在我身体里物理化的，以及我的身体是如何释放它的。它将是你自己的，或者将用画笔、相机快门或在一个角色中释放它，或者类似的东西。
And not to say that everything comes from that or a camera flick or in a character or something. And not to say that everything comes from that source because it's not the source of everything. I don't think trauma is the source of everything. A lot of the times, you know, it's how you cope with these things that can be a lot of the source of something. There can be unconscious things that are the source of it too.
并不是说一切都来自那个来源，或者相机快门或在一个角色中，或者类似的东西。并不是说一切都来自那个来源，因为那不是一切的来源。我不认为创伤是一切的来源。很多时候，你知道，你如何应对这些事情才是很多东西的来源。也可能有一些无意识的东西是它的来源。
But, you know, I think a lot of the source of something. There can be unconscious things that are the source of it too. But I think a lot of coping mechanisms to deal with whatever you've dealt with in your life, if you want to call it trauma or just being a kid, getting raised in America and having a great family, you're going to find ways to cope with your life and use things to your advantage. Sometimes that will let you ease into becoming a tax accountant because that's exactly what you want, which is super legitimate and very fulfilling for you.
但是，你知道，我认为很多东西的来源。也可能有一些无意识的东西是它的来源。但我认为很多应对机制来处理你在生活中处理过的任何事情，如果你想称之为创伤，或者只是作为一个孩子，在美国长大，有一个很棒的家庭，你会找到应对生活的方法，并利用事物来发挥你的优势。有时这会让你轻松地成为一名税务会计师，因为那正是你想要的，这非常合法，对你来说也非常充实。
And sometimes it makes you want to paint, which can be legitimate fulfilling as well. Well, I think I'm not like a huge fan of that like tortured artist myth that the trauma is the source of the creativity But I do think that what happens is that the intuitive Function gets kind of bound up with trauma in a way that you have to go back through the trauma to access the intuition Under it and that you know kind of until you do that there's
有时它让你想画画，这也可以是合法的充实。嗯，我想我不是那种受折磨的艺术家神话的忠实粉丝，即创伤是创造力的来源。但我确实认为发生的事情是，直觉功能以一种你必须回到创伤中去获取其下的直觉的方式与创伤结合在一起，你知道，在你这样做之前，有
You know places it takes you back to a place where you remember things that you've kind of forgotten and it's an interesting way Look at it. Yeah, but that intuition might be well, maybe, maybe you know the intuition is there, but the trust isn't there with you. Exactly. Yeah, maybe it's a matter of going back in there to that place and finding that initial trust you had with yourself before it was, you know, broken, separate with your parents or the world or whatever. Well I think that intuition and trauma both come from that you know really subcortical brain stem stuff and we can't tell them apart and we get kind of afraid of them and the real kind of healing somatic work helps you tell the difference between the intuition response and the trauma
你知道，它把你带回一个你记得你已经忘记的事情的地方，这是一个有趣的看待方式。是的，但那种直觉可能是……也许，也许你知道直觉在那里，但信任不在你身上。没错。是的，也许这是一个回到那个地方并找到你最初对自己拥有的信任的问题，在它被，你知道，打破，与你的父母或世界或任何东西分离之前。嗯，我认为直觉和创伤都来自那种，你知道，非常皮层下的脑干东西，我们无法区分它们，我们有点害怕它们，真正的那种治愈性躯体工作可以帮助你区分直觉反应和创伤
response and you have to go back with the trauma response to kind of do that but I mean when I do somatic work with my patients, I tell them, you know, like whatever this thing is, you know, if your heart feels like a black hole and it's under your shoulder blade or the gut is locking up or, you know, the arms want to just kind of fight and elbows want to fight, whatever it is, make contact with that. This sounds crazy, but you will find your medium, you know, try and sing, try and write a poem, try and journal it, try and draw it.
反应，你必须带着创伤反应回去做那种事情，但我的意思是，当我和我的病人做躯体工作时，我告诉他们，你知道，无论这是什么东西，你知道，如果你的心脏感觉像一个黑洞，它在你的肩胛骨下，或者肠道锁住了，或者，你知道，手臂想要战斗，肘部想要战斗，无论它是什么，与它接触。这听起来很疯狂，但你会找到你的媒介，你知道，尝试唱歌，尝试写一首诗，尝试写日记，尝试画出来。
And while you're there and you you're gonna go on a lot of failed dates, a lot of these are not your medium, but there's gonna be one that you just, all of a sudden, it's gotta come out that way. And you never would have known that was there. And it is wild. I mean, there's people that have never painted, never written, never whatever, they come in with this thing
当你在那里的时候，你会经历很多失败的约会，很多这些不是你的媒介，但会有一个你突然，它必须那样出来。你永远不会知道它在那里。这太疯狂了。我的意思是，有些人从来没有画过画，从来没有写过东西，从来没有做过什么，他们带着这个东西进来
and it's beautiful and they're better. But there is something about the contacting the semantic and then going all the way through it and it just kind of has what it wants to say. And I don't know, like some people do that with a line and painting and other people kind of connect to it different ways, but it is neat that that is in everybody.
它是美丽的，他们变得更好了。但确实有一些关于接触语义然后一直贯穿它的东西，它只是有一种它想说的话。我不知道，就像有些人用线条和绘画来做，而另一些人以不同的方式与它连接，但它在每个人身上都有，这很整洁。
I think it is, and I think a lot of people, you say they they they don't allow themselves to engage with that just because not because they're they're terrified or anything. They just it's just not they're in their worldview to to do that. Maybe they love golfing for fuck's sake, you know, and those four hours of golfing every every Sunday with their buddies, that's their way to kind of be connected with that thing. And if they thought about the world in a different way, maybe they would take those four hours and say, hey, wait a minute. What if I started painting something, 180 degrees from where they're sitting at this point.
我认为是这样，而且我认为很多人，你说他们……他们不允许自己参与其中，不是因为他们……他们很害怕或什么的。他们只是……这只是不在他们的世界观中去做。也许他们喜欢打高尔夫球，该死，你知道，每个周日和他们的伙伴打四个小时的高尔夫球，那是他们与那个东西连接的方式。如果他们以不同的方式思考世界，也许他们会拿出那四个小时说，嘿，等一下。如果我开始画点什么呢，从他们此时坐的地方旋转180度。
Maybe they try this other thing. I don't know if that's in our culture to really do that. More now than ever before, I think, to be able to try that 180 from you. I think these alternative modalities are really coming online now in a way like never before. There's more people that, if you bring up MDMA to party or MDMA therapy to party, people go, shit, I heard about that and that guy and this and Rick Doven and all that. It starts to go and more people as opposed to even four years ago, more people now are aware of it at the very least.
也许他们尝试这个别的东西。我不知道我们的文化中是否真的有那样做。我认为现在比以往任何时候都更能尝试那种180度的转变。我认为这些替代疗法现在真的以一种前所未有的方式上线了。有更多的人，如果你在聚会上提到MDMA，或者在聚会上提到MDMA治疗，人们会说，该死，我听说过那个，那个家伙和这个，还有里克·多文（Rick Doblin）等等。它开始传播，更多的人，与四年前相比，现在更多的人至少意识到了它。
If you get in those algorithms on Instagram, that's all you get for days on end, and it can bash your head in a good way to just open you up to this other idea about the world. Does there's something besides lots of titties? Yeah. Nothing wrong with lots of titties, but God, when you get stuck, if you look at some girl who's standing around in her bikini on your Instagram stories or something, and she's some influencer or something, the the and changing. They don't know that I'm controlling it. And a lot of that stuff, I just never really would have ever thought that that would work. And now it's like being, you know, kind of validated.
如果你进入Instagram上的那些算法，你整天得到的都是那些东西，它可以以一种好的方式冲击你的大脑，让你对这个关于世界的其他想法敞开心扉。除了很多胸部之外还有别的东西吗？是的。有很多胸部没什么错，但天哪，当你被困住时，如果你看Instagram故事上某个穿着比基尼的女孩，或者她是某个网红什么的，那个……和改变。他们不知道我在控制它。很多那种东西，我从来没想过那会奏效。现在它就像被，你知道，某种程度上验证了。
Some of it is validated in research, other, you know, places it catches on clinically. But a lot of people are like, well, you should do psilocybin or something. And it's like, you know, the red tape of that in Alabama, I don't want to mess with. But even if it was 100%, you know, green light, I'm not going to get, you to get a Baptist minister to take mushrooms, but I can make you look at a stick and you'll peel the meat off your soul and talk to God. Those reactions are wild. It's kind of interesting. You might need to work on that.
其中一些在研究中得到了验证，其他，你知道，在临床上流行的地方。但很多人说，嗯，你应该服用裸盖菇素什么的。就像，你知道，在阿拉巴马州那样的繁文缛节，我不想惹麻烦。但即使它是100%，你知道，绿灯，我也不会让你让一个浸信会牧师服用蘑菇，但我可以让你看一根棍子，你会从你的灵魂上剥下肉，并与上帝交谈。那些反应太疯狂了。这很有趣。你可能需要在那方面下点功夫。
You might need to get some carnival barker in you to get that Baptist minister to take psilocybin. That's the fucking truth. Because when he starts going in there and seeing all the color of the blood up like the the the the the the the the
你可能需要让你内心有一些嘉年华叫卖者的特质，才能让那个浸信会牧师服用裸盖菇素。那是他妈的事实。因为当他开始进入那里并看到所有血液的颜色时，就像那个……那个……那个……那个……那个……
the the the the the the the I want to be respectful of your time. You have any future projects that you want to pitch? We'll definitely link to the book. Thanks. Is there any other rabbit holes you want to go down
那个……那个……那个……那个……我想尊重你的时间。你有什么想要推销的未来项目吗？我们肯定会链接到这本书。谢谢。还有什么你想深入研究的兔子洞吗？
or new projects you got in the works that you can talk about? There's a couple of pictures come out in August that I'm in. One is called Americana. This guy, Tony Toast, directed a really great road and directed a really great indie feature. Lord is in it. This guy, Eric Dane is in it. I have a small part in it, but it's a good kind of rural American thriller about a ghost shirt, a Native American ghost shirt that's very valuable, but everybody wants to get their hands on. And then another movie that's coming out the end of August, I believe, or mid-August, and
或者你手头有什么可以谈论的新项目吗？八月份有几部电影要上映，我参与了。一部叫《美国人》（Americana）。这个家伙，托尼·托斯特（Tony Tost），导演了一部非常棒的公路片，导演了一部非常棒的独立长片。洛德（Lord）在里面。这个家伙，埃里克·戴恩（Eric Dane）在里面。我在里面有一个小角色，但这是一部关于一件鬼衬衫的很好的农村美国惊悚片，一件非常有价值的美国原住民鬼衬衫，但每个人都想得到它。然后另一部电影在八月底，我相信，或者八月中旬上映，并且
the beginning of August, a movie called Weapons is coming out. And that's a really great, this kid, Zach Craig, kid, he's something, he's in his mid-30s or something, but so he's a kid, yeah. But he did this movie called Barbarian, a horror movie that some people have seen. Man, this one, Weapons is a giant leap forward creatively and storytelling wise and filmmaking wise. It's just a great leap he's taken and it's a really dark, really kind of slow moving, hypnotic, pull you in kind of thriller almost horror movie kind of not it's not a real, you know Stake through the heart horror movie, but it'll it'll really mess you up. It's great
八月初，一部叫《武器》（Weapons）的电影要上映。那是一部非常棒的，这个孩子，扎克·克雷格（Zach Cregger），孩子，他很厉害，他30多岁什么的，所以他是个孩子，是的。但他拍了那部叫《野蛮人》（Barbarian）的电影，一部有些人看过的恐怖片。天哪，这一部，《武器》在创意、叙事和电影制作方面是一个巨大的飞跃。他取得了一个巨大的飞跃，这是一部非常黑暗、非常缓慢、催眠、把你拉进去的惊悚片，几乎是恐怖片，有点……它不是一部真正的，你知道，刺穿心脏的恐怖片，但它真的会把你搞得一团糟。这很棒。
It's a great picture and they were gonna release it in You know January or February I think Paramount was and they they saw a cut of it They went oh shit. We got to get this out in the biggest weekend of the summer. Come on beginning of summer So that'll be fun. So those things are coming up. Okay So the and so the weapons is coming out this summer next summer this summer this summer weapons Weapons in American are both coming up this this August. Awesome. Yeah, well, I'll link to it if there's a page up for it Yeah, man, cool anything, you know kind of about your history the the we just say the topic is consciousness so we can put a bunch of stuff underneath underneath that. The topic is life.
这是一部很棒的电影，他们本来打算在，你知道，一月或二月发行，我想派拉蒙是这样，他们看到了剪辑版。他们说，哦，该死。我们必须在夏天最大的周末把它推出来。来吧，夏天开始的时候。所以那会很有趣。所以那些事情即将到来。好的，所以……所以《武器》今年夏天上映，明年夏天，今年夏天，今年夏天，《武器》。《武器》和《美国人》都在今年八月上映。太棒了。是的，好吧，如果有页面，我会链接到它。是的，伙计，酷，任何，你知道，关于你的历史，我们只是说主题是意识，所以我们可以在下面放一堆东西。主题是生活。
Well, thank you so much for your thoughtfulness and your work. It's it's it's always always a pleasure when I when I see you in something. I know I'm in for a treat. But so we have to please check out the book American Sugar Gristle, we'll link to that and then the upcoming movies in the in the in the show. Thanks, man. Appreciate it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嗯，非常感谢你的深思熟虑和你的工作。每当我看到你出现在什么东西里，总是，总是很高兴。我知道我会有所收获。但是，所以我们必须，请查看这本书《美国糖软骨》（American Sugar Gristle），我们会链接到它，然后在节目中链接到即将上映的电影。谢谢，伙计。很感激。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。